greetings from podcast Ville it's so
brock Toba [__] uncle Joey's
still here and slinging dick the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by my bookie listen we're going into
the [__] hurricane we're going into
major hurricane money season right now
basketball starts next [__] week you
got the World Series
you got the NFL you got the NBA you got
[__] UFC you got to praying mantises
fight in China somewhere I got my bookie
doll Agee let's face it where your
betting is just important as who you
betting on I wouldn't be telling you
guys to bet with them if they weren't
the [__] best so do the smart
thing if you're gonna bet this season
bet with my bookie dot AG listen what
we're gonna do is this Monday Night
Football whatever it was last night
we're gonna start the week off you have
the World Series this week you got
Thursday Night Football you got college
football listen double your first
deposit right now use promo code shirt
caq rch take out a hundred percent of
your bonus on your initial deposit up to
$1,000 all right who the [__] can do
that for you my bookie dot AG that's why
visit them today grab a pen that's my
bookie my bo o ki e dot a G and don't
forget to use promo code Church when
you're creating your account to claim
the bonus in yo check my [__]
Instagram on Thursday I'll be dropping
the video this week teach you how to
make bets and how to put your [__]
get your life together all right uncle
Joey is your [__] bookie so go
to my bookie dot AG the church is also
brought to you by zip recruiter you like
Joey who's your cruise ship recruiter
were you nuts or what
zipper coolest number one hiring site
out there
zip recruiter doesn't depend on
candidates finding you it finds them
okay for you it's technology that
identifies people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job so you get the qualified
candidates fast no drama no mm
applications you gotta call people
forget about that whether you got a
small business or big business
zip recruiter is for you so with results
like that it's no wonder four out of
five employers who post on zip recruiter
get quality candidates within the first
day we're not playing around here CY zip
recruit is effective for businesses of
all sizes go to zip recruiter right now
zip recruited calm slash Church grab
that [__] Pentagon zip recruiter
dot-com slash Church that zip recruited
cop I'm gonna give it to you for free
that's it
it's Tuesday you know how I show up I
myself like the three wise men with
gifts I don't [__] around go to zip
recruiter dot-com slash Church zip
recruiter the smartest way to hire
it's Tuesday [__] morning take
this meal lee-sia what's up you bad
[__] uncle Joey here coming off
a tremendous [__] weekend i standing
on my family I want to see the angelina
jolie movie with my the girls on friday
night whatever isn't maleficent and then
to saturday i want to give a big thanks
to make my hand hook me up with
tremendous tickets and backstage passes
see pat benatar
nice and tremendous neil giraldo 63
still shred in the [__] guitar it
just inspires the [__] ah yes beautiful
night sitting yeah like I took 250
milligrams you know me yeah I know you
I put the half a xanax to calm the horse
right but you just can't walk into a
place on 250 milligrams
yeah so why not take a hundred
milligrams because why do you have
effect respectively you know take 100
milligrams to go see Pat been around
play for that huh she's not gonna want
to play for that if you're only on 100
[__] just shut it down
let me tell you something there was you
could smell sperm
yeah from all the chicks to hit you with
their best shot right maybe one yeah
they were all we're all those chicks
maybe one yeah was still there Salomon
how they hold it up hold it up they lost
a finger yeah in the war something with
the hepatitis but they're invincible
yeah it was great it was great for the
Pope
it's what he it taught me humility it
taught me that you really have to love
what you do in your life yes I'm sitting
in the small theater say band theater I
think I asked my agent today what it's
at he said 1800 let's be honest with you
she sold maybe 1400 seats okay there was
400 comps I was two of them you know
this whole area she's coming home you
know what man I saw her play the
Menelaus he's 66 years old yeah
and on her whatever she's worth thirty
two million dollars so you gotta ask
yourself you're 66 years old what would
make you do a six-month white tour they
do a light tour two tree shows a week
for six months then they take off that's
a page from your book the light tour the
light yeah oh yeah like yeah keep alive
and just stayed this is art this is a
Lauren we got to keep doing it last
night I went home that Declassified was
on CNN
[__] less than zero yeah but Donny
Julius best [__] performance yeah I
had met with these kids their parents
died I knew their mom passed away and
they just reached out I wanted to talk
to me so yeah to come out to lunch of my
wife and the father came and we you know
so I was just it was just a deep day I
went to the [__] gym like a thousand
things yesterday yeah unless i'm cinda
oh [__] Tom nice talk I'm gonna go to
commies over 15 [__] Dallas Laurel
Canyon and at nine o'clock I know who
the [__] am i what am i a [__] and
again we go back to what you want to do
and what needs to be right you know I
looked at my Twitter I saw they put the
schedule up I saw was just me and
Whitney Cummings I'm Rick Ingram yeah
you know it was gonna be a white show
[__] show so that
Kancil what's my excuse cuz my knee
hurts him what I gotta something happen
my name my knees bruised no I'm not
gonna cancel [__] Pat Benatar went
down there for peanuts yesterday uh-huh
it's 66 years old and I'm husband 63 and
he was up there playing the piano so
just teaches humility mm-hmm that it's
not always gonna be [__] an arena
yeah it's not always gonna be a theater
but you understood that the reason why
you keep doing this because you like yes
that happened to me recently I went to a
coffee shop gig just to keep sharp on an
off week and I saw the audience and it
was like 12 people and I was almost like
[__] this I'm going home but then I was
like I'm here I'm gonna feel way worse
if I don't go up I'm going up I had a
great time and a story I was glad I did
it and you didn't do it for the paycheck
no way you didn't do it that's when you
know you're on to something
yeah we've been I've been talking about
this on this podcast for a few weeks now
since Andrew Schultz cabinet uh-huh
because in LA lately I haven't seen more
and more people everybody wants to go to
heaven but nobody wants to die right
it's like this is how much you have to
love the shame I want to see Guns
N'Roses a couple weeks ago it was
Citibank that means Citibank gave him a
milk fete Miller I'll let you [__] in my
mouth right you don't say yeah like fake
mill right now that's where I tell you
[__] in my mouth yeah
I'll [__] drink white vinegar for a
year yeah and I have more [__] than
you yeah but I'll be making a contract a
little Chinese guy that got beat up on
United I have an island right next to
his
Sharon [__] are moving them over yeah
Jeffrey Epstein on the helicopter fam I
like pilot everybody's sucking dick for
Halloween no candy here every sucking
thing
you want chocolate let me put in your
ass first
it's nice and candy-coated for you the
[__] you know but listen
you know they got 8 million for they did
the Palladium who's a great show
yeah I learned a lot I learned about
performance Axl Rose was great but then
you went to bat Benatar and you learned
about humility yeah you go out there
[__] some people would say why are we
gonna go down there for 14 on the seats
I got a house in Calabasas she got a
Butler's yeah the whole thing but that's
when you know wow she did this for love
and then here I was in the same spot
last time I come Robert Downey jr.
hasn't even died yet I gotta watch this
little [__] die yeah after they take him
to the hotel they [__] did that yeah
because I think less than zero was at
the end that quaaludes but the beginning
of viagra and some people still had them
together yeah I'm the way down I'm
thinking about what would have happened
to women there would have been women
missing limbs today
if quaaludes a viagra would have been
around yeah not that Cosby would have
[__] you all night long right say none
about Cosby sure but just would have
brought in general the one eight-ball
eating way ludes and [__] and sucking
yeah
when I was 21 that's six Baggett's right
you know like and I didn't come quick
then like it was like G minutes that's
48 minutes a [__] viagra you get the
bat put in here yeah [__] 40 minutes
the next day you're not walking right
you blinking you got [__] PPS beam
your Z yes you got [__] right thank god
those drugs didn't overlap yes so I
couldn't we with the robert downey died
right and i'm sitting they have people
like one and robert downey thing what's
the [__] movie with you bother me I
was gonna say like how did Pat Benatar
make you think about all this because I
was sitting there having a good time at
my house last night the Lord's Day and I
got a spot at the store and I'm like
while I stick my foot in my mouth
and commit to this [__] right I don't
like doing nothing on Sunday yeah
but Sunday's at the store yeah there's
nobody there to bother you nobody
you mean like comics what do you mean
everybody there's nobody there
I took twenty pictures last night mm-hm
but there's nobody there
I gotta have to talk to people right you
know when you call it a stronger Tuesday
night you got to prepare yourself
mentally it's like going to the train
station mean you went in Philly you know
there's noise yeah
bus is leaving for Connecticut train is
leaving for Australia too many books and
eBooks that who books yeah you know so
when you walk those through you have to
be prepared not that it's a pain he
asked to me but I'm older right
well I wake up now and then want like
let's say you come in and when you bring
your girlfriend yeah it's the first time
I made them we got hi we giggle and [__]
like that
yeah I'll think about my night all day
and I don't drink great you know it's
like I mean quaaludes memory erases yeah
I don't remember to like for that [__]
was there last night
uh-huh then I'm calling a man who's good
yeah yeah yeah he's like I was about to
call you
[__] I end up getting drunk with Luis
Gomez you know whatever the [__] it is
right but like for me I wake up in the
morning that's how overwhelming it is
it's it's 1,200 people compared to 600
people yeah
mister instead of there being nine
waitresses there was three mm-hmm one
bartender you know yeah it's just a
slower knife the shows are still back
yeah shows were both sold out main one
was sold out original yeah just there
was not that much you know come out of
the Whitney yeah I talked to Dean I
talked to some girl Dean was talking to
okay I spoke to an English guy mm-hmm I
went on stage that came at a couple
pictures uh-huh I brought up Rick
Ingraham uh-huh and I looked around and
there was nobody around that's awesome
the whole way was completely empty so
let me go I was on the hill at ten
[__] thirty ago am i ain't I happy I
[__] followed through instead of
[__] canceling you know was I [__]
happy so you just learn little things
every day man that's it yeah that's a
lot nicer I know Jimmy when you go there
and there's eight billion people and
they want to talk your ear off and do
nothing against them it's just one guy
after the next guy after the next guy
after the next guy gets a little
exhausting I lovely yeah
that I don't even bring them to the
store on Tuesdays oh yeah
cuz I gotta be responsible for I lose
them right you know you get lost in the
crowd Lee it sold out but no cheerful
he's got to sit in the hallway and then
some guy comes up in Singapore sigh at
ICU from podcast I know it's like I walk
into this you know yeah so it's very
hard to bring people like Tuesdays and I
love my friends but one of my worst
nightmares is at eight o'clock when I
phone during a home one of my friends to
say what time you leaving for the
strongly [__] hmm I'll be there by 9:30
we're gonna be there with a group of
eight from work ah [__] cuz it's Tuesday
night there's gonna be enough people
down there mm-hmm and usually I get like
ten surprises when I go down look at
last Tuesday I went down and there was a
kid what's the third grade with Nash
yeah yeah I'm the girl with the high
school with the visited me when I was in
the [__] house cars yeah you know I
mean this is the camee store this is
what are they so enough about the
company stole what's going on with you
brother I am living in New York and I'm
traveling around the world and doing
stand-up comedy you miss California a
little bit a lot of you been gone I've
been gone for a year and a half that's
it that's it two years yeah but one
winter oh this is gonna be your third
this is gonna be kind of my third winter
I was going back and forth for a while
so you could say almost two years really
but uh yeah I've been there for a while
now I miss the Mexican food I miss my
friends I don't miss the traffic in LA
I'm created a sign for yourself I always
tell my wife what's that well you showed
me the gift of travel again right showed
me the gift of the Train right and how
important oh yeah how what a gift it is
that's great in the North once again
when I met you in Provence and he was
sitting there like James Bond the hotel
um problem right the hotel um problem is
gonna shake him down my flight was the
way oh [__] so I got in late and it was
really weird that I go
I'm sorry if I kept you here I think we
ordered food something like that where
are you in the lobby yeah we yeah and I
said to him why don't you get him he
goes the Train like like it was like
nothing like I just got off it's so easy
cuz it's right in the middle of the city
yeah I just took a train got out and
walk the block yeah that's it it always
drops you off right in the city no
matter where you are where you need to
be oh yeah I'm like really mm-hmm
so this is the advantages of being a
comic in New York yeah the cities are so
close together and they're so easy to
get to you know you don't have to drive
if you don't want to you can take the
trains I take buses okay well I'm
hearing more more more more from people
who I think are smart people are telling
me that they're not even driving to San
Diego oh no I heard the trends great
I've been taking the train for a while I
heard that to San Diego is a blast you
it's beautiful
you'll bow to wherever you need to go
uber back and take the train back my
friend's husband just got a job in
Falcons and you know unemployed five
months you can't beggars can't be
choosey yeah it's a great paying job he
was telling me go the only sacrifices I
have to get up two days a week at 4:00
in the morning and take the train down
everybody girls listen took two hours
I'm in the computer there's Wi-Fi yeah
you're not driving you not cursing you
know sweat or not yeah so I really
enjoyed every single train ride I took
with you that station we were when I
bought the [__] bubblegum hell yeah
chick-fil-a yeah I shall the ATM that
was DC yeah I don't know I think we were
pulling up I'm like wonder this place is
my Congress we're rolling awesome make
the loop and I'm like what mall economy
those it was the fire station yeah then
the next day I think I dropped you off
at the Philly one yeah not a homeless
person around I was scared for his life
yeah like I'm like you really want to go
to Philly if I'm in the [__] morning
yeah take the mustard like are you
[__] [__] because the bust in New
York sucks but the train from Philly to
New York is easy you know what I mean
that's why I went into Philly there's no
train from Atlantic City to New York
unfortunately so
dude we never talked about this remember
when we were on the way to the airport
in the train station in the limo and it
just pulls off on the side of the
highway
and then our driver gets out to go to
talk to the guy and then everybody gets
out on a limo and starts walking towards
our limo do you remember this and we
were both like what the [__] is this
what the [__] is this we were both gonna
be like pop pop like like it was this
weird scenario we're on the side of the
highway yeah yeah but the guy got a car
I didn't even say a word to us he just
got in the car he was wearing pajamas it
was the weirdest [__] thing to happen
at 5:00 in the morning do you remember
this we didn't know what the [__] what
the [__] what the [__] okay we're not
gonna die and I went back to sleep I
don't know if you remember that or not
you know you don't when you're up at
5:00 in the final and you go to bed at
1:30 yeah you're really just walking on
a cloud it's really scary and you don't
really know it - you're in Detroit
Airport uh-huh
that's the airport that lets you know
you're in a Twilight Zone I'm not awake
but not really they have purple lights
yeah when you connect there there is a
walk of death that is underneath the
airport that you better be in shape
uh-huh it's the walk of debt they have
Nia and that's what you realize you're
in a [__] twilight don't arrive in
the morning yeah you're awake but you're
not really grasping even if you try and
coffee and whatever that's why I don't
do a lot like I used to have a bad habit
of getting up and call them people
uh-huh can I get off the phone I'd say
[__] I said a lot of wrong haha I'm not
fully awake get some coffee in you right
you know listen to some music take your
[__] yeah bong hit and then you make
your cause yeah we get up and whatever
you know I was doing blow I get up in a
bed oh yeah so I'd wake up the next one
and call the agent it's just on the rap
a lot of
come on I'll come down I'm not in for
the leader Superman you weigh 400 pounds
did you ever think about that
but in my cocaine mind I should have
read for Superman sure you know I'm
exaggerating here but I get the point
yeah in those days I would get up and
unleash on the agency I know one right
man what the [__] haven't gone out in
two days
yeah like never like Joey what the [__]
you went on for three audition last week
I don't give a [__] yeah last week was
last week [__] get me something yeah
yeah I was theatrical I'm - yeah the
worst thing I ever did was get breakdown
uh-huh that's the worst thing that's the
reality figuring out you were right for
about a million project you're right for
about a million prize but you don't know
why they're not calling you in right
refuse you still going on IMDB looking
for names and numbers and you're like
that full-time chef at all and right and
I always believed that I mean I gotta be
honest cuz I must leave balls about this
I always believed that I lost a few jobs
because of my baby you're in those days
mm-hmm how aggressive I was uh-huh but I
would also not be able to sleep if I
wasn't that aggressive right yeah what
is the what is the medium what is the
middle ground because you can't just sit
around but then you can't intimidate or
overdo it with people to get annoyed
with you to go there Lori yeah a lot of
being that there was a casting agent in
town named Rick Pagano mm-hmm and I did
a movie from and a couple things
happened on this set that [__] missile
they did not involve me ah
but in those days I kind of took the
blame for it uh-huh and I'll never
forget he had a project that I was
perfect for the pay was perfect the role
was perfect and finally I got a little
you know a little farmers market on
Hollywood on Sundays yeah I like coal
and all those red creepy streets I saw
and I [__] one of them I already know
I've sent you 18 envelopes you know I
called your office 16 times I'm perfect
for that role he goes did you attend to
the director had a nephew that was
perfect for that role because that's
what happened right and I'm like so you
couldn't [__] call me you know I was
a little upset with him now he never put
me in nothing haha but that's what that
taught me that you don't know what's
going on with that project of course now
the directors thinking about something
the producer is thinking about somebody
they put it why they put it out to plunk
me is what pisses me off right it's like
you know that commercial mayhem mm-hmm
they made up 200 people reefer 200
regular people like me you and we yeah
go to [__] 200 South LaBrea
and I knew like three guys that went to
the callback yeah when they saw the guy
that got hired
they were heartbroken mm-hmm because
they're like why'd you waste our time
cuz they desired him you think without
an audition they already know you
already had them but I know yeah they
just this is a write-off sitting and
watching you for a week I keep Lee happy
yeah go find somebody yeah yeah you're
doing great legal
I already got somebody I already signed
somebody right but part of the casting
sag program you have to have some yeah
make that when you write something if
you're a writer you're a writer uh-huh
when you're writing some aren't you
writing it with somebody in [__] mind
course okay then then what the [__] are
you talking about right when I'm writing
the role of moosh I'm thinking about we
write when I sold the show to Fox
yeah motion my telemarketing office was
leaked right that's it I was baseball
flea a kid out of college young I knew
his father his smile that made me take
him and he's not a Salesman right and I
read there I'm like what type of Jew are
you fine you say I know Jews that sell
[__] in his sleep I get the only Jew
that can't [__] [__] sell but I
love him he's like my god nephew or
whatever I mean the pilot when you write
you already have somebody in mind yeah
mayhem the guy I had four I had a guy
called something I gave him like a
prison name it was Nick
the Torah right it was Nick Turturro's
character was it gonna be Nick no I
don't know if the net the network will
say no right that's what people all know
yeah that you could write for people I
can write know this is going what's the
guy did a star is born
Bradley Q Riley Cooper I can write a
role for Bradley Cooper that doesn't
mean Bradley Cooper's gonna take it
right so everything adjust after that
Bradley Cooper turned it down and
somebody else who looks like Bradley
Cooper turning it down hmm
so now I gotta switch this character I
gotta make him a garbage man trying to
look like Johnny lavaca there whatever
fact so yeah getting the breakdowns it
pissed me off
mm-hmm because every day to be eight
submissions and I was getting them I was
so addicted like my addictive
personality from cocaine I had become I
knew I would
there was no way they were gonna look at
me as a comic uh-huh there was no way my
door was gonna be open as a comic this
is 20 years ago he's talking about the
2005 I was already blackballed in this
town yeah I was a cokehead and I was a
store comic yeah
dirty Rogan cause problem but you were
getting acting work at that time no no I
decided to attack acting yeah because I
couldn't open a door in common yeah
couldn't get a manager couldn't get an
agent right everyone to Montreal nobody
ever talked to me about nothing right
but I'm doing spots at the store so
something's gotta be there something's
happening something you got a talent you
got somebody nobody's talking to me
right so in my mind I go let me open up
a different door let me open up the
acting doors yeah take an acting classes
talk with the actors they told me about
this thing called the breakdown
week at him but you're not supposed to
know okay then I met somebody who knows
you on also in theory morning at 3:00 in
the morning
uh-huh so I would wake up at 6:00
sometimes I would sleep an hour at the
dual code is that when you started
waking up early I know you like to wake
up or no I've always walked but that's
their only bread that's just the [__]
world yeah okay so you get up at 6:00
and it would be a hundred and four or
five pages that 160 pages break down
right and you got to sit there with
glasses yeah no book on the pad it's
exhausting and
write it down and scroll and they're
looking for midgets [__] Bowie you
swallow a sword you know you'd read this
[__] yeah I'll never forget but I read
for one and I actually read it and went
wow and then I actually get the call for
it and I was like what and it was like a
commercial with alligators uh-huh and
you were gonna actually go into an ocean
like a river uh-huh shoot this with the
alligators oh just a metal case since it
for jackass three it was for something
and you submitted for this I went that
incident you could submit right from it
you had it but you could call your agent
and be okay oh you're a punk ass that's
what you do you type the information
down and when your agent gets to work
the first email Jodie is what you want
this is what you submit me for it today
I'll call you in an hour mm-hmm and I
would call and go what happened with
this we called and let the message what
happened with this they didn't return
our call what I'm with this there's
nobody answered now I got to go to work
right now I gotta get an envelope put in
and drive it down there personally
that's how we do that oh yeah you're
gonna envelope down there bring the
[__] head shot
[__] oh okay head shot a [__] bio oh
okay I thought you meant an envelope
full of money no no I think I'm looking
for a job I wouldn't go down that's a
[__] job right so those days element
in those days they would either be a
large amount large amount has uh an
office and like a caster ah
their main offices yeah and then when
they get called to do something at NBC
they catch you from NBC but I would find
out where their main office
uh-huh and I would hit that main offices
problem is at the main offices there's
no receptionist mm-hmm so you just
believe in a dry that's a 50/50 you're
just leaving it somewhere you leave it
under the door
gotcha you zip it under the door uh-huh
if there's a receptionist you halfway
there because at least you have contact
right see you the nicest person you
could be with the reset
right god forbid she watches at your
Rogan podcast came into the office yeah
I do
there's always you know people always go
to them have enough first time finding
an agent
have you been down it yeah right no I
still referrals yeah you're down there
yeah it's good advice gotta get
twenty-five numbers you know do five
Monday five Tuesday 5 Wednesday five
Thursday right Friday they don't want to
see nobody right won't see anybody on
Friday no no I'm not even myself only
one bro yeah yeah you don't want nobody
so you bring it down Monday Tuesday and
you're never gonna know I know what kid
who walked the three onto the headshot
he got a call the next day yeah unseen
they signed up so don't tell me right
you know you got a do it was a chick and
he was a good look right and you gotta
do stuff he ran back there and told him
you got to see this guy he's hot he's
Spanish
who yard sign them yeah but if he was
sent the submission he wouldn't seem
that receptionist he's in a pile he's in
a while even though you know literally
or if you try not to end up in the pile
right so you have to do the things that
don't end up in the pile yeah and this
is what everything what doesn't what
where it formally spinning my wheels in
that direction why do I want to spend in
that direction
mmm-hmm I'm wasting my [__] time I
heard something that was very
interesting once to me I heard that a
casting directors job was to find the
right actor for that job uh-huh the
quickest most efficient way that turned
me around at that time as an actor I
said over there looking for me
I got a present myself right I'm like my
own zip recruited mm-hm you know I'm
saying yeah [__] pop-up but you gotta
find your own candidates mm-hmm well I'm
a candidate for this you might have
learned all my because I'm not with CAA
or innovative I'm with the coloring book
haha they got no juice right you know
they got no juice to get me in here so I
gotta create my own juice and that's
what I would do i yeah and then I
started putting the auditions on tape
mm-hmm for that more ready yeah like for
a movie that was in pre-production just
and atone you have a friend that yeah
you know you've been here for 10 years
everybody has a friend there was a comic
no huh that gave up and became an agent
right
up and lit yeah hell I see em right
little koala don't ya see if you got the
script for American Gangster I was just
reading it sent me on the mail
I'll give it to nobody else I won't just
send it to me they do that all the time
right so I would get those scripts and
look through and send a package that's
cool and sometimes you get it and
sometimes you don't but that happens
anyways long hard bro
I dropped it off on a Tuesday what the
tape they wouldn't see me uh-huh
there you are right there opposed to I
am in the poster not that poster
whatever you're on the planet that put
yeah well that movie came out big [__]
got arrested for domestic violence I
missed that
so the first set of posters I'm in yeah
once he got arrested didn't want me they
can you know too much like so he took me
out of the poster that's one story the
other story is the [__] produces me I
give a [__] I still got the original
ones with me and AH some daughter of
Salomon's right did you did you create
chaos on the set or was that did they
just like you for [__] for dumb reasons
I think I was dead because of Adam
uh-huh okay I wasn't there because
everybody agreed on me gotcha and then
once I got on there not in New Mexico
but once we got up here you know you
could only had a problem for so long
yeah catch ya know when you come in and
you have bags under your eyes and you
know yeah we can
wasn't that the movie you showed up on
and you were completely broke you had
like 35 cents in your pocket and then
you just got all this you were loving
the perdy on the first day yeah first
day when I got that yeah I think I had
$25 and I gave the limo driver five they
sent a limo to come get me yeah to the
table right and then straight to the
airport yeah I'm thinking Ilona how I X
will head at the [__] van nuys yeah a
private jet oh yeah you know yeah I got
[__] $20 enjoy yeah that's always so
fun YTM card yeah you know when you get
to a hotel
you gotta give'm ATM crap I get to the
hotel yeah that's what happened to me I
was taping live at Gotham for comedy sin
I spent all my money just getting from
JFK to Midtown and then they asked me
for you know the hotel the the
incidentals I'm like I got nothing
luckily my friend who was also taping
lived with his dad and he had tons of
money on his credit card and I got to
sleep indoors that night but that's so
weird oh you're going to tape TV it's
the weirdest business I've taken
Greyhound buses and private jets in the
same month several times just you know
it's nutty just this is what keeps you
you know Pacino on the devil's advocate
yeah he goes you take the subway well
what's his name John wick says yeah we
take the subway yeah [__] loaded I
think it was I always want to keep my
ear to the ground right you know so it's
really nice to take private jets and all
that stuff yeah but you always will end
up on the ground the bench always you
know it's like I told my man reno/tahoe
I'm back to the ghetto yeah you know and
as long as you know that going in listen
man I take uberx mm-hmm I wake up some
mornings it's just $10 I'm over X I'll
take an uber X with 10 40 Ricans will
fit you never get over how even tell me
how bad so [__] so I get 10 off on
uber X today I'm powering everybody in
the neighborhood it we're sitting on
laps we're breathing on one another I
don't give a [__] yeah when I went to
New York to shoot that movie I became
like platinum uh-huh I get all these
[__] weird things like 25 hours
offers you get this car really boom yeah
I'll kill that cop you're pushing me to
that car yeah [__] I'll take it right
very very very very good
I love Hoover you know America has been
many many many good to people yes like
baseball yeah America very good yeah
anybody very good to me
I love don't do the planned right no
more oh the scheduled ride they [__]
you over that's not good
they [__] that's not good they
canceled they charge you like five hours
yeah
you're waiting for the airport I got a
call again yeah you Mobile's that
happened to me I'm trying to catch a
flight somebody's coming to get me for
20 minutes and then they cancel when the
one minute away I'm like now I got to
start from scratch you met my mother and
five starting Monday you that who but
lax is non-existent well I'm Burbank all
day so I ain't worried about it going
JetBlue yeah Burbank to JFK Michael come
on man what the [__] else and that's a
red-eye - yeah there's a 958 I think
it's a little earlier than right there's
two of them yes added another one yeah
there was one a day JFK Burbank Burbank
chance Butte I just don't have men they
just don't have men so wait why can't
you burn lax because they're gonna drop
you off at a terminal and then you have
to take a bus no that's that's that's
worthless well just take the bus so I
can imagine how big the lines are gonna
be to wait for the bus so I've walked
onto lax property before that's all
right man I just walked on I like
running across roads I've seen [__]
that yeah getting pin for being into
Isis just [__] yeah it's terrible
that's starting Monday you can't take it
over to Elliot 29 all right
hey guys Lee's life so you have to go to
a terminal and then take a bus that
circles the terminals they're gonna
guarantee you that you had a terminal
are we three minutes and all that's
that's no good that's no good [__] lax
all together now and other people are
saying that what they should do is make
a site in where they parked the cars
right across like the parking garages to
put a dad's coming ba ba na but I see
but talking from a consumer side yeah
which I have to be honest with you
unless you fly into LA so I heard LAX at
night well after six o'clock during the
week and I heard Sunday night's is yeah
many people were thinking of flying out
to LAX Sunday nights you can
get out there I know I fly in early you
know yeah of course yeah I'm dying at
nine Malone mm-hmm you gotta see that
looks like out there to gotten over yeah
and the taxis it look like they got AIDS
you said money taxis yeah you can't
blame them right because I know when I
take an old bump it's $30 the end but
yeah yeah bill I take the old bikes it's
$40 right what about JFK is not not
great though either JFK yeah but you
know I don't have to take a car out of
JFK I can get on a train once again the
Train saves the day and take the train
from JFK but absolutely if it's at a
decent hour definitely and it's only
like seven seven eight bucks to get all
the way home what kind of trail is it
there's a you get on the AirTrain that
takes you to the subway take the subway
home the regular subway people look it's
a pain in the ass it's a pain in the ass
but it's cheap and I kind of like it
better than waiting for a taxi if I'm in
the mood let's put it that way
you know by the way I have a new travel
podcast called Road heads really came
out today it's all about this stuff
yeah it's all about traveling and
traveling with no money which I've done
several times millions of times it feels
like you would jump over a counter in
Denver Airport or steal a pack of
cigarettes now that's you and going to
the bathroom to spark it up no you did
that how'd that go I got away with I'm
here yeah I can't tell you how many
times out of Terminal 4849 American
uh-huh that last convenience store I
just went to the airport to shop with
them really that last convenience store
American airline terminal it was this
before 9/11 this was till about eight
years ago okay so about 2010 I made it a
habit just [__] it I couldn't afford to
eat at the hamburger stand another right
try we're going to one of those things
take was turkey Swiss sandwiches yeah
and there for two days I'd take a Rocky
Mountain Post
what would he call those the New York
Post yeah at LAX they saw the New York
most really for three dollars okay three
dollars for a newspaper yeah so I take a
[__] can of soda put it in my pocket
that'd be a lot of people that I just
take it yeah paper but that stale turkey
sandwich with the little side packages
the mayonnaise ah and I'd trickle my way
to the door little by little right walk
out four years I still but you jump
behind the counter to get the cigarettes
Denver one time yeah well I went to
shoot analyze this analyze that yeah
they I went to the audition they didn't
pay for the audition they paid my flight
to shoot but didn't pay for my flight to
the audition right so my buddy threw me
out of PAP buddy pass mmm-hmm
fly standby new frontier or alliance oh
my god which was completely my nightmare
no kidding well like I was supposed to
audition an afternoon at 2:00 when I got
off the plane at 11:00 in the morning
there was no luggage my luggage is in
Tallahassee fine so it was all those
tiny animals I basically went to New
York had a bar on an awesome my friend
get a warm-up suit some reason my
stepfather gave me a ring that day
cousin my birthday uh-huh he gave me a
ring the only thing he ever gave me
after my mom died was a nice big gold
diamond ring and I water into the
audition how to buy a wall of Ceuta
sneakers I didn't get my luggage so I
got back to Hawaii
Jesus so that night I slept in the
[__] warm-up suit
yeah the next day I got another buddy of
mine borrow another hundred to go back
to Modell's
yeah motels I got like warm-up pants
correct want your pants yes and there
was no jeans
sure I would be easier with sweats and a
hooded sweatshirt yeah I have to buy a
belt too pants and [__] god of belts
and suspenders a [__] yeah so at that
time I was in for 18 hours like 370 some
stayed another day and then like the guy
who drove me to the airport and have the
nerve to ask him he had just drove me
for free yeah I'll have the nerve to ask
him telling me ten bucks to eat
something
yeah and I got on that plane with like
two bucks mm-hmm I think I hate what I
was something at Newark I didn't
shoplift at Newark but once I got the
Denver I had no [__] choice and I was
smoking that I damn right you were and I
had a connecting airline a connecting
flight
yeah you cannot walk out of Denver a
smoke and walk back I know it's an hour
ah
you will miss your flight yeah so I
didn't I had to let Newark one night and
I [__] almost died and I'm never
forget Newark that I was walking I saw
them walking towards me with the dog I
had the reefer in my pocket
and I ran into a bathroom and hit the
reefer in a toilet roll yeah somebody
else toilet you know yeah a toilet but I
I put it in a roll gotcha I walked out
once the dog passed by one back in
Hawley shared the WIDA
rolled it in the bathroom and ran back
outside and yeah this has to be 2002
okay I'm outside smoking the [__]
number of my head's on a swivel
I'm smoking a number and as I'm gonna go
throw the roach away the cop with the
dog is 10 feet away from me I gently
flicked the roach and I make-believe
like I'm already saying Leslie it's like
man I love your show on agent arrest me
even if he wanted to be right you know I
just got a thousand of those hell yeah
he's put on the way back and then why
couldn't a it right like I hadn't smoked
in like [__] 10 hours mmm
I had no money and I went to a store
that was closing mm-hmm so I had gone
somewhere the gateway right just barely
yeah it was Apple right there's not
crazy I just went looked around yeah
reached over right took a pack of
Marlboro Lights
I took the [__] lighter yeah and I
ran and I [__] act over smoked in the
store dead I smoked like two in the
store that's not a planet that's
craziness I store them
to Lubbock to do froggy bottoms ah
transferring Houston I was in Houston
and my flight was scheduled for like
let's say 10:00 in the morning
and the only reason why I was going
early because they wanted me to do radio
uh-huh
I just wanted to get a hotel and get
saddled and snort coke and blum right no
I'm gonna forget staying at that Airport
all day broke because they kept saying
Southwest will give you a $250 voucher
if you get off this one yeah
so that whole day I was at that Airport
where maybe two bucks no phone I just
have a pager right I would just have
change in my pocket if I had to call
somebody calling card yeah and I would
just shoplift at those airports no
kidding I'm very ashamed to say it but
it's the truth
yeah you're hungry man amen you got a
survivor's Yeah right and never mind
when you start getting on buses
I got hours of mm-hmm you know when you
pull into the Charlotte when you're
connecting from Charlotte you want a DC
yeah I got bad news for you there's
nothing open in Charlotte at the bus
station now can they just have a little
area open and you look up and there's a
vending machine yeah I know now you're
eating Reese's Pieces your rienner yeah
you're eating potato chips
sour cream and onion hopefully they're
some of them will have the sausage with
the pollen yeah or some cheese and
crackers picked that resemble good you
have no idea when you travel as a comic
and you're working for 500 a week you
got to make everything count and the
buses 90 hours yeah you know and you
just like that some people yeah
sandwiches you know I got big at that
time yes I was very lazy yeah but my
diet I was only 19 rings and yeah
cheeseburgers in the club and jalapenos
I was trying to take all my payment and
beer and food for a while I blew it you
know because I wasn't getting paid
enough I'm like give me more food give
me more beer I don't know why I mean I
know I can't put that in my ATM but I
was like just keep it coming I put on
tons away couple years ago there's a
couple uses a comic we just stopped
you're stuck in limbo one you just stuck
every years yeah finally say to yourself
I'm very happy paying rent and me yeah
however that is right if it means I
gotta go down to the Hermosa mm-hm it's
that comedy club comedy magic yeah I'm
gonna forget Ralphie being broke is [__]
going yeah that's the only reason I
called down there player the feed you
say free if he does something nice they
give you something to go exactly which
is really rare you can get two dinners
in - woman yeah
salmon yeah when you break a steak and
you [__] go [__] out of here stop it
yeah sorry I get it now sometimes when I
don't know you don't have a spot what's
up full charge what do want to eat steak
[__]
I'll go down there go down the comedy
magic I don't have a spot sometimes I
probably shouldn't put that out there
now everybody's gonna do it but I've
done it why not
hungry always after you hungry you
always play qe your with you oh no I'm
fine but have a hole in your stomach
you're ready to [__] blood but your
[__] ego it's like man get some later
Oh Joe you gotta eat no wait yeah come
over you sure yeah it made special and
you like I just ate 20 minutes ago yeah
well you have any 20 days again wait
that [__] dry cereal 11 o'clock on a
qualm with no milk you even thought
about putting water and it's all
expanding your stomach like that [__]
Special K yummy boxes and rice pressure
okay
easy just buy the [__] boxes treat it
with your hands like there's a point
where I don't really know what happened
me because I wasn't eating enough to
justify the weight I was gaining uh-huh
but it was metabolism sitting on those
buses for eight hours and stress can do
it too sitting in all those buses will
asleep at me when the sleep apnea came
on yeah I had that initial yeah yeah
because you really your body's releasing
cortisol ah so it's releasing like a
danger let the and cortisol gets you fat
and I got you your backs well like when
you see people with the hunch
yeah that's cortisol and that's because
they have sleep apnea or is there gonna
have stress stress stress stress stress
cortisol yeah body
she's bad yeah but you learn all about
those stainless you know from going out
and you learn about your body and what
it can handle and what I gotta be on see
the other night I got Pat Benatar night
I got so I came home I was looking at
the refrigerator I usually like a
protein bar share Apple I found my
daughter's Halloween cam little yeah you
know there was no point so I'm like two
points apiece I had like three of those
they're fluffy in the middle and
chocolate outside
Oh thousand dollar bar not a Hershey's
bar not it's not a milky way is it Babe
Ruth
no it's like a milky way Three
Musketeers yeah pretty much good that's
some [__] right there but it's
delicious it's called nougat no I had
three of them yeah before I went to bed
yeah a little sleep I don't know how
with the sugar content but just the
three of those trolls yeah oh yeah feel
too good the next well it's heaven while
it's happened I had two mistakes last
week I hate that and one that I had
double damn mm-hmm other work and that's
destroy it just destroyed my internal
combustion system my [__] was coming out
you see I like this table is yeah I did
I thought it came out for today
guitar [__] like it's just destroyed my
internal I had to go back to probiotics
I know how to drink that [__] [__]
okay yeah that's how my body can't
handle it no kidding dude no that's
worse than spam I'm not kidding you guys
I'm not making [__] up here my body shut
down on that like sardines when I was in
prison eight more soybeans and Gilligan
yeah I was eating sardines like it was
my island you know yeah and bad once I
got on the prison I ate so many [__]
sardines are you fish right I ain't
[__] no soy bean those days are over
and I could go for that happy Yahoo
let's do it oh [__] day job fool
let's start on our so she did
a couple weeks yeah I had a nice happy
hour cuz I keep it simple not sure
no more compound sushi is too many
points gotcha oh just keep it with the
spicy tuna six points four months for
eating spicy tuna what look
but now he's not that spicy corn is
delicious this month it just eats spicy
tuna shrimp and there's one of regular
tunings from tempura yeah so I can't
take them noise in the back you're right
that's an entry level here oh yeah why
person I can't take them no but yeah I
eat the real deal I get the [__] blue
crab yeah blue crab oh yeah god why the
row with the rabbit and [__] yeah you
speaking my language I'll buy them and
he almost killed him last week bother
feet I gave him a blue crab I put him
out in the Sun for six minutes yeah
we're smoking one of those crazy joints
but once I got to do it's breaking out
because I was coughing it wasn't me I'm
gonna just win this coughing burn
calories a little bit when he wasn't
doing nothing
yeah he took to it I looked down and up
is that going to New York you look you
look up you see ya beautiful city you
look down you're back on same [__]
thing
I look up I look up he's sweating
profusely from vitamin B so you don't go
outside that much vampire no bro
he hates the Sun is that right I mean
when I walk from the car to somewhere
else yeah that's it huh but it's
different when I was in New York I walk
it's one right here it's boring as [__]
nothing to do nothing I like walking a
with am I trying to say like I love
walking in New York but at least in New
York you won't go to a store there's
people sitting on the floor like it's
fun there's stuff to see [__] in my
[__] you got Popeyes Chicken now yeah
so why am I gonna walk to Popeyes chip
and you got a hotdog stand across the
street yeah you look like a doctor you
got [__] johns across oh yeah that's
a barrel laughs John's
what's John's if they pretended to bond
which is nice I love that what it's John
yeah the ripoff I love that thousand
Russian people hit they hit your car
tell me go in there the two cashiers
don't speak English I hate every time I
go and I see something by a car those
Russians yeah yeah yeah this is why
people can't have those Russian Jews
every time you go in there you see a
[__] ambulance yeah there's a Russian
Jew going down over there I don't go on
there my wife goes yeah pull the breads
good the breads were edge really good
and the coke cuts yeah I don't they have
like they have like that ham that are
real life yeah yeah it sells out my
lunch time but then yeah John's always
looks like it's John raided yeah it
always looks like somebody came in and
grabbed him I don't I don't know John's
and the one Felipe Guzman what's that
[__] creep yeah he's right yeah Foofa
less in Hollywood yeah you gotta be out
of your mind
mm-hmm and at that area then it was
really bad yeah will you stop the park
under the food for us and walk upstairs
and fear for your life right ladies and
gentlemen you fear for your life and
this is uncle Joey telling and my wife
she's a sweetheart she used to go let's
go there at 7:00 most people write
witnesses since that area isn't a good
no kid anyway they have it that's
Western mmm-hmm Western let me see how
crazy Worcester let's talk about how
what's all about Western because when I
first moved here the pussycat theater
was right there
am I right about that the porno theater
right on Western and sunset but it was
actually on Western Western and sunset
so is just north of Sunset the Pussycat
theater is one of the last porno theater
still around in the late 90s it was
still around Wow
I don't now do you see big I just know
that I used to go to sprint over there
uh-huh
Hollywood and Western has done the
lumber you place the hardware right all
that in you going in there's Mexicans
outside right and they have a Mexican
food catering truck uh-huh those
Mexicans did not slip cuz the Mexicans
that were landscapers and builders that
want hungry would stand
if you ever want good Mexican food in
Hollywood get about all those cliche
restaurants the truck go to the truck at
what what's the name of that whole debo
or people yeah and I'm not trying to be
funny here I I know they have a carne
asada yeah
Oh like a thing on a ball and a thin
snake on a bone man with rice and beans
Lee it's a little blah but I used to be
they used to be a sprint there there's a
Hawaiian restaurant thing man yeah and
next to the Hawaiian restaurant thing
there's like a a thing will you buy
sheds uh-huh and then across the figures
of McDonald's right on Frank said in
Hollywood yes there's a McDonald's
behind the McDonald's is food for less
yeah that was that neighborhood that
Street after sunset go past sunset at
ninth and see what you see for those
next three blocks right it's not mad max
it's not pretty
yeah so one night I go to el compadre
the cop coke mm-hmm I'm listening this
has to be I quit doing coke in 2007 2004
you know like I said sometimes you don't
need material right in your life you
just have calmly appears and that time I
had a lot of calm that came to me and
one night I was walking into our
compadre through the back door the cop
from the Armenian but before I could get
to the Armenian a kid came up to me on a
bicycle yeah is the true story says talk
to me shake almost on I thought I know
ah
I think he knew me no mom you shard okay
so it was like 2005 okay cuz I dealt
with him for two years only and I'd done
with him an extreme situation uh-huh so
this is how this guy soldier come he
would talk he talked to me that first
time say hey come on stop
mama body goes get double condom like
what are you looking for and I didn't
know if the Armenian was there I didn't
know right but equal you know he goes
hey lo in this pocket bro right outside
it's gotta be 8:30 at night there's
people in the balcony and el compadre
what a parking lot yeah
goes in his pocket takes out a cockroach
and just [__] puts it in my nose
really you'll see it like this
that's delivery right there should write
my nose with his [__] eight with his
little HIV finger Brian is hepatitis C
because that's how you get hepatitis by
snorting coke with dollar bills
ah yeah that's how a lot of people have
hepatitis today though now get him a
question yes did you snort coke from a
straw or intervene right because when
you put your straw and your nose and
then you put in your nose that's how
people will get C appetite of see the
happy yeah yeah this guy like hepatitis
C or whatever it doesn't really matter
he put the coke rock in my nose and
immediately I was [__] up uh-huh he
goes what do you want and they go what's
a gram really good idea he just said so
I gave him 60 bucks and no rapid no
nothing just took a bag out
Hey mm ah I put my hand out he yeah I'm
gonna choke on my hand Wow
I just closed oh no that's a lot of coke
first time Beale yeah and he goes if you
want to find me I'm on Sunset in western
coke for less it's fire
uh-huh it's fine nice so in those days I
had like three or four drug business
because I didn't want them to know how
much coke I was really right you don't
want to be judged by your drug dealer at
your menial project lead guitar playing
Oakland Padre ah after my black buddy be
money and I had John blaze the bartender
and all those Hollywood clubs
yeah sounds from man I had four
different drug dealers and nobody knew
nobody knew I had tabs I write I always
had a tab with D money
mm-hmm and I wouldn't have a tab with
John blaze I always had a tab with the
Armenian but the guitar player no
compadre wouldn't give me a tab yeah so
it was nights where you're all tapped up
right no the two dealers aren't around
yeah why gotta pay for this so one night
I'm sitting in my apartment I'm John I'm
about to jerk off for the eat
sure I have to get some more coke and
also a herd come to sunset in Weston I'm
always there l my yellow flashback yeah
the movie like I heard like that voice
like you could do it you like what easy
about the lousiest women yeah you get
like a vision of your phonebook yeah
obi-wan Kenobi you know you say uh
what's by the man Uncle Ben yeah yeah I
don't know responsibility with great
power comes great man I hear you know I
hear like yeah right but we'll sunset in
western with debt comes with more hooker
yeah with great power comes
responsibility a voice give me I'll
spider-man yeah so I got my car and I
went to the street pass Western uh-huh
Hollywood made it right yeah and the Sun
set and I drove up and I'm like looking
around I don't know what they yell for
in the morning that part of town is kind
of empty
I get the Holly with the West like that
like that I was a red light I'm like
okay look at the McDonald's it's open
that could they closed it yeah that's
why I bought breakfast from my wife and
their two girlfriends
I adore the mercy was born uh-huh I got
the call like four word we're gonna go
into labor and I stopped McDonald's
right like I brought breakfast like that
like yeah I'm like I don't even know if
I should make a noise if I got a beep
right or whatever so dog the light
changes I'm like the second car though
and the life changed and I'm driving but
guess what what at the next light
there's a red light at the next corner a
red light what do you think comes up to
me and this little bicycle Yoda yo you
come in and you find me it was a [__]
morning right below the pullover
so right there by sensor we just pulled
over on his bicycle he came around
opened up the [__] car door first
thing he does is make sure you're not a
cop he puts a coke rock in your notes oh
really
conversation gotcha there's no
conversation
what does that accomplish Blake if you
got coke rock on your nose you can't be
a cop if he puts it in and you snorted
he knows you're not a cop gotchas mine
gotcha he would give you a little taste
yeah Wow I'm ready to buy and you're
like 50 they give you a little coke
thing with no package no none
mm-hmm you just be driving home on
sunset and I love coke like you'll hand
full of coke like a delivery boy from
dominos windows rolled up you think I
know how many times I gave me coke in
the palm of my hand
uh-huh with not a [__] but that's how
bad Western yeah to be so food flashes
right then there's something else right
there dude that's kind of scary
everything over there sketchy but now
they're making a shopping mall out of it
aren't they okay but you know what that
McDonald's is yeah I'll cross the street
from that to let you guys know how
[__] crazy Hollywood is yeah was one
of the biggest casting offices in this
town right really yeah that right across
the street from that McDonald's look
there's like a bunch of like you know
sell your kids that's those type of
buildings that I get along tonight yeah
yeah so you thought it till the Mexican
cartel right and then there's like a
little house that's very you'd think
like who would live there 20 years ago
there's a vault that was going to a
movie
mm-hmm [__] the director from
Drugstore Cowboy got fan sent less fan
Sam we're gonna do a movie about us a
singer I used to stand-ups
ah and we all we went to the studio
first and read but the final callback
was at that house I don't be calling
that like a 10:00 in the morning right
like what is this and that was the first
time ever that I went into a room true
although no [__] but I go out all the
studio's and [__] I been to there's
never an actor there right I come to the
haunted house I'm West and this [__]
Travolta is a [__] does Vansant
that's crazy man I was I was laughing
the other day because I watch I've been
watching Cheers and Joey always says how
old la is they had a scene in LA I buy
that that clown liquor store yeah it
looks to say right you're not changing
David ain't broke don't fix it
the fathers are violent yeah yeah that's
scary drunk clown that whole block looks
the same from like 1990 cheese was 1990
and that block still looks the same and
I'm in the last couple seasons now okay
Cheers was like early 80s to early 90s
that's funny because last night they had
Weston zero on yeah and they scroll
through different places of Beverly
Hills and know those places as well yeah
Beverly Hills know one they scrolled
through Hollywood I saw Hollywood neon
that's all I remember
right but this time it's like when you
watched Lethal Weapon ah
the first lethal weapon is hilarious
that's a neighborhood I lived it yeah
one minute he's on Schrader and two
minutes later he's fight and what's the
name under the 101 right some pops it is
impossible it's impossible money goes
I'm gonna go ahead flow I'll cut them
off on vine yeah you need a helicopter
when you watch Pretty Woman yeah watch
Pretty Woman you'll die when they go
down Hollywood Boulevard you're like oh
my god that's still there yeah the one
with valley girl right valley girl will
really kill you yeah SWAT what when they
would shoot a SWAT I live on that
neighborhood I don't know why SWAT don't
the last one they just shot uh-huh 2005
the corner of code they shoot that I'm
Wilcox uh-huh look at the sign that's
what [__] around with Boulevard I lived
right around the [__] corner yeah
when they did the bus and the people
escape and all that rats so it's really
weed when you live on the East Coast and
you've never come out here yeah the
best-case scenario is that show 24 Jack
Bauer will go from like Simi Valley to
Venice Beach in like 15 minutes
you know he'd be all over the place zero
shows the Yuma yeah
what's the beach what's the beach yeah I
think it'd be like where's Adrian well
he likes to go to Zuma Beach and like it
took him like eight minutes there was no
track and no scene in less than zero was
I know and there was like eight people
on the beach yeah now which is funny cuz
I actually did read the book believe it
or not and they mentioned traffic in
that book a lot I think it's when
traffic was just starting in the 80s
like LA was starting to get out of
control in the 70s I think and all the
smoke and everything I ended up reading
that book after before the movie I
didn't see the movie when it came out I
read the book first and then I didn't
see the movie until like the year 2000
or something so you would when you read
the book was the movie out yeah yeah the
movie has been out forever and the the
book is nothing like the movie
how old did the book come out before the
movie I really don't know but I don't
think it was that long I remember I
rented that when I finally did rent that
movie it was like it was a weird thing
with my video store clerk I was like hey
where's less than zero I want to watch
that movie and he's like it's in the the
G&L section and he's like looking at the
table I'm like Gaea now he's like gay
and lesbian and I was like all right and
he just seemed like really weird with me
after that we were like boys until that
moment and then all of a sudden he
thought I was [__] weird too guy that
turned me on to that movie like I wasn't
like those type of movies I don't like
this Holly yeah I'm always the guy that
turned me on that movie was a big-time
cokehead and smoked it uh-huh when I
went to his house to do something he
goes hey it looks like he's getting that
right really watch the movies when he's
got the [__] around his gums and he's
sweating because his father's house it
just last night disturbed me oh yeah
yeah cuz now I'm seeing what you
reminded me of me at that yeah you know
less than zeros movie about a [__]
kid was a junkie he's got Remy losing
this unrealistic [__] world of
Beverly Hills where the first Christmas
party is 200 TVs it's Christmas yeah
they just have people dancing this is
just unrealistic yeah but it probably
does happen these are the sons of movie
stars right you know there's no parents
around none of the movies when he went
back to his house he wanted into a gym
there
topples [__] golds in Venice I'm
saying yeah they have tons of money but
I watched a movie and I was thinking of
cancel my spot at the store like I said
yeah until we started throwing the
figure $50,000 around didn't and then he
went to his friend Andrew McCarthy
Niko's I need the $50,000 yeah that's
why isn't the G&L sex right they would
just pick him up and they go to drop him
off for something right and the god the
bullies from Karate Kid yeah yeah yeah
what's aapke I wasn't the main guy I
forget it was it spares it um
nah [__] whatever one of those [__]
that was big in those eighties yeah
please is the guy that's driving them
then he escapes and he goes right what's
his name but it's weird are you ready
for this this is scary this is why I had
to get out of the house last yeah I
still know 40 probably is the guitar
player no it's a lot of money how do you
how long did that take your record is
there interest
come on what and then but I was fronting
the quarter four ounces at a time
uh-huh so listen I'm stressing out late
oh no no no Hey this movie was stressing
me out just thinking about it right oh
just one guy forty I owed her partner
his partner 620 and I owe their friend
another I wasn't that why am i nervous
Jesus okay $30,000 a week yeah 1986 them
23 years old yeah and that's exactly
what I have hazy shade of winter I was
behind a hundred grand and cocaine money
that's insane
I can't he had borrowed money for a
restaurant ah that movie he wanted to
borrow right fifty thousand for a
restaurant to open up a business some
have failed
huh huh this was I would just go to
somebody and go I need that again there
would go where's the money from the
original I gave it out I'm waiting on
the front I had to pay for this just
give it to me again next time I see I'll
pay you
ha ha I would show up again with a story
uh-huh a nice kept cable and then I
would go back to the guy and all this
time in [__] I got robbed two weeks
ago I just didn't have your heart too
tight yeah you gotta make me start over
again he would give me another half holy
[__] it was just because were you
keeping track of what you owed I was he
oh yeah yeah okay sure yeah I know my
mind he wasn't gonna say dick right I
know in my mind he wasn't gonna say dick
and then one day I went to a bar and I
bumped into it him and her were getting
it together so they would get it cheaper
huh
so I bumped into uh she's like why don't
you ever get [__] from me
I'm like I would but I'm with this other
yeah goes not from now on you're from me
follow me home I'll give you a half a
kilo okay yeah I'm gonna turn it down
you know in those days people come up to
you anything you you know anybody who
does coke know why I was gonna give you
a couple out to see you to move just
leaving me it maybe I wasn't being that
bag as soon as you walked up of [__]
doors you say how much of that 100 grand
did uses know how much did he sell all
of it you started off in only somebody
gives you [__] somebody gives you oh
my god eight ounces of coke they want
twelve hundred apiece ok what's 8 times
12 1976 ok so now you got to give him
9600 hours let's say you bump into I'm
just saying this is just I'd say you
bump into Kate quickly you have 96
hundred dollars worth of cocaine in your
pocket and you throw all cut on that and
you're gonna make fifteen thousand and
you still gonna keep it out for you so
to [__] go crazy but guess what
you go to the County store you give a
little bit for this guy you give a
little bit now you sell most of it and
now you start getting all that cash
right it's not your cash so now you're
at the county store it's ten to two you
got six thousand in your pocket okay
quickly he's looking rather than
[__] yeah if she's like well I
really hang on to my plans because I
know like [__] let's go to this
bandit
it's not your money but what do you give
a [__] it's 4:00 in the morning a cake
Quigley's then you got six ounces of
coke in your bottle you're gonna lie
some [__] on fire you're gonna do
everything the hub of make a mop okay so
what do you know do you gonna play
[__] well I can't take you home
because my mother know about the six
grand the whip that's right and you're
gonna get the best room at that Stan
this is Kate Quigley the body of a
thoroughbred okay and you're gonna go up
there and guess what what do you think
what are you doing you might have some
coke on you might wanna break that out
what are you gonna drink drinking water
yeah no so that refrigerator that's
eight dollars a bottle yeah you're doing
the whole thing and you get another case
you're gonna call them and say look it I
mean I got this little blonde up here
send me up another refrigerator because
this is going down right how much is the
refrigerant 800 don't man bring one out
up it's not my mother and I'll say you
were supposed to sell Kate Quigley's the
[__] vacuum
that goes that house jack
plus the one you're gonna take out in
the morning and what are you gonna do a
level and they call you mister cyan you
check it out and you look over and she's
passed out with no panties you gonna
check out now I'm gonna stay it for
another day by the way you got room
service send up 18 eggs bacon everything
cuz I got a blonde next to me and I
still got a half a bag left and she
don't even know what country she's at
now your 40 grand in debt and you just
dropped six thousand I can't tell y'all
anxious a ham for you you just dropped 6
G's in that whole [__] night you
normally nights I went on the
one man I went out with four ounces of
coke uh-huh the guys like what time
element all right let's just go to New
Year's Eve hey New Year's Eve 85 I'm
this guy I've been working this pigeon
for a month
ah he had heard all the rumors he was
watching me like a hawk right he was
giving me an eight ball at a time and
then I worked myself up to a quarter but
I knew the day was coming I was gonna
get him off-guard
uh-huh and then the halite was getting
more to a half hour to me what time I
even mean with this money I'm gonna see
you tonight but he knew ya never to give
me the coconuts 8:00 tomorrow
oh you're not gonna get it right you're
gonna give it to me at midnight you
better get to that ball or any bar in
that facility by 3:00 cause I'm at one
of those bars trying to pick up Frank
trying to hook up with somebody take him
to a hotel so he would meet me again at
2:00 2:30 so for like three two months I
had to be by the ball with him then New
Year's he's like no I came and I'm going
away at five o'clock and I'm gonna have
to give you more than but by this time
we're fine uh-huh and he gave me two
ounces big mistake
right he goes call me at midnight lastly
yeah I'll call you with the money and
[__] a D by 8:00 in the morning I was in
the car to Cresskill I never saw that
[__] again yeah because that was
broke right
that ounce he gave me that went that
night yeah because once I you know it's
like I told somebody they're they just
do a bumper you know a buddy of mine
struggling with drugs a young kid I said
come listen I'd rather you do a bump I'm
a weak delusion but right and he goes I
can't throw a bump and always turns into
an eighth one then so be it
it always does nobody just does a bump
man yeah once you open up the bump you
just walked into Willy Wonka's chocolate
factory
now you got two hours to [__] kill
right saying so it's just it's uh that's
how fat Lee I went through Lee I was
making money and still out snorting and
out spending my makings
like it was kinda I had three different
drug dealers at once so how do you feel
walking around with a hundred thousand
dollars and it's not like
one wherever they go let's get something
straight
what nobody in 1986 not me I never had
more than $8,000 no no I'm saying that
you owe $100,000 yes to someone who it's
not like Capital One where they call you
like hey we want this money it's like
they're gonna they swing a bat at ya how
do you know all these people were not
gonna forget about it oh my god they
were gonna threaten their we're gonna
threaten me you can give me a heart
attack
yeah and try to talk to me they were not
gonna struggle better okay okay today
we're gonna let me work it off God you
know get them more more more no all
right the last lady
yeah there's no coming back
were you the exception do other people
get away with stuff like that it was
just you listen if you don't try it yeah
in those days you gotta remember what
what would it turn from 1982 84 it went
from everybody having a sit there be
having coke yeah then they flooded the
market then people will come up to you
outside your brother-in-law's the
Spanish dude that's married to your
white chair and he's always been a nice
guy
uh-huh but also they started driving a
Cadillac and awesome they go on to Porto
Rico what are they doing and one day
comes up news I ain't man I don't know
you get rid of this I have a few friends
I know Lea no Joey yeah [__] Rene
whatever they snow a little coke but he
leaves you a [__] in the four ounces
yeah okay what you're gonna sell us is
an eight ball a week ah pretty soon
you're gonna start doing a bun and then
you want to do a bump then you on the
road and pretty soon you snorting an
ounce right so now you're you know you
got to cut the coke to make the profit
back right coke it was always your
question was how do I walk around how do
you feel yeah
today know know that when that day when
you check out of the hotel finally and
you're just going a pink dot are you
looking over your shoulder you know so
you don't think that guy cares about
that money anymore
oh no I bumped into okay I left the Navy
I left my left Snowmass ioad m40 the
chick 20 nah the other chick like 30 I
had 10 people I own five thousands of
them Wow
you know like 10 people I would say
invest with me give me 5000 if you'd
like 7500 in two days
ah burn God right but it was think about
it today because how stupid can you be
you don't say like how can you be I had
like four or five people I owed you know
five thousand last two yeah
the video store I just cleaned up oh
yeah the video so I work that everything
good right project this I took
everything that night and would you go
back to work or was at the last day they
wrote my wife a letter the video people
oh yeah
like Christmas like we left Thanksgiving
week like ah ha Thanksgiving of 86 I
just snapped
uh-huh I just snapped I went the city
mark in Snowmass I ordered the turkey
I was supposed to pick it up on Thursday
I must have invited 15 people to my
house ah for Thanksgiving Day on
Thursday okay uh-huh
I had this whole thing planned I had
this this and I was on the spring for
the whole thing even though I own eighty
thousand dollars
I'm springing for 2000 yes and I finally
got my last investor him and his sister
were partners on this restaurant called
Paula friends okay and he was the cook
in fact I'm gonna [__] Momo
and he's like hey how do I invest with
you I was that and I held them off he
was like like my last yeah he was like
the one I was gonna hit but I held them
off for so long but he couldn't wait to
give me the money
yeah like I was gonna give me a 500 but
I wanted to give you $1,000 hold on I
had three of those guys I'm dying to
give me money
I knew they were grapes give away that
money yeah they couldn't wait to be in
the COBE they couldn't wait but there
was so anxious how to hold them off
yeah like to make them even hungry like
come on
and yeah to be more what missing out on
millions so there were guys like that
would they would they buy coke from me
uh-huh then they would turn their
customers on to me like they're friends
uh-huh
and they would like it's also much more
let me be your partner then I would just
saw them like a line that won't listen
when we go deep yeah I got these mules
coming up in Columbia I would just do
the speech
oh my god I'd have nothing yeah I'm
nothing I barely had food in the [__]
out uh and I would tell them listen I
got these mules coming up when I get
these kids six kilos can you come up
with like four thousand yeah we'll make
a ton of money and I'd leave them with
that
uh-huh need see me a week later man I
thought about your proposition how about
I gave you a ten thousand I'm like oh
you're like the Bernie Madoff of code
this is the crazy what the yeah and I
had all these people and I had people
that I paid back there were people I
made a lot of money
yeah there were people that I respected
they may give me five thousand and I
already had the coke sold yeah by the
time I got back I give them that sixty
two hundred yeah or sixty five on it
that's what I did with people like I can
see why you went to the store last night
that's a lot to think about
what do you be this [__] dead in the
past so this is 1986 yeah so I scheduled
this big Thanksgiving dinner now at that
time my paranoia height skyrocket okay
who the DEA was watching I knew the
local aha so I couldn't snort in my
house anymore
okay so I would go to lien a week
understand it I want you to get a hotel
and get the [__] out don't come back
okay give me two hundred bucks
so I would go to his house that's how
bad my paranoia was and while I was at
his house I'd still go crazy
look at the windows my windows taking
the phone so oh my god I'm a part I was
one of those guys yeah carpet Holly [__]
became what
what Sagada Eddie what's the fire that
broke this fireplace
Oh because Tony Ferguson he said there
was Martians living in this big bug this
fireplace I know those people I think
you're talking about mayhem so
Thanksgiving of 86 that Thursday I was
supposed to have a big party but that
Wednesday afternoon I picked up two
ounces of this coke yeah that was [__]
phenomenal uh-huh my buddy caddos house
and I gave him like an a-bomb okay no
you gotta go he's like what am I gonna
go and go [__] to help ya I don't
want the same ball or not yeah he took
the eight ball he disappeared
uh-huh and [__] uh I stayed in this
apartment all night Wednesday snore they
forget about things yeah I [__]
snorted
what do you do when you snort cocaine by
yourself you just hanging out jerk-off I
had a girl that would come over and suck
my dick
uh-huh oh can I [__] in poker Teddy
okay she was like married she looked
unlike b-24 uh-huh I mean it was just
terrible
right she would come over so there was a
to cotton there was like three or four
different
condominium things up in Snowmass that's
a Greek side there was the battleship
and then I used to ice I did
construction work and I won then had
four apartments so I stole the keys to
all four so I would go into different
apartments when the people are the tab
and just not cold yeah I was crazy
so that whole day Thanksgiving I didn't
come home uh-huh my poor girlfriend at
the time was psych she had a host
without you oh yeah well you're friends
with my friend no Turkey because I've
never picked up a turkey a turkey from
the guys special ah that guy never
talked to me again
oh my god wall day for you with the
turkeys I couldn't kill him if he was
only kill him and then give him oh my
god a live turkey all day oh yeah oh she
walked in my house Friday 11 o'clock you
pardon the turkey I'm sorry go ahead
where you say I walked in my house
Friday morning at 11 o'clock for the
point ah my girlfriend up
my wife [__] are broken uh-huh she's
like lesson man I've had [__] 50
people here people quality and I wanna
[__] scab and John I said okay let me
just beat these guys my when could I do
from Paul LaFrance uh-huh
I got him for like 6,000 or something
uh-huh I had another guy who went to
flight 2000 and I had this bag of pot I
bought I bought this bag of weed yeah
did you even smoke pot back then oh yeah
okay okay I had this bag of pot that I
bought for [__] 300 bucks
uh-huh that looked like it would put you
on Mars mmm but did nothing to you
okay you could smoke it for two hours
straight nothing absolutely nothing but
it looked tremendous gotcha
so the lady Neal II thought I owed maybe
25 to the time yeah I was all packed up
packed up at six or seven cash in my
pocket
ah my girlfriend's crying at the house
we've you we had a dog Oh Hercules yeah
we had a monster a two-door Mazda uh-huh
the thing was [__] bouncing from all
our clothes shoes yeah and she's like
what are we gonna do for Coco one last
idea
give me that pound of weed I took that
pound of weed and I knocked on and there
was nearly I knocked on the door what's
the expression my head my heart in my
head yeah my heart my my hat you had
your hand my hand yeah and she goes you
better have my mother go I don't know
where the [__] you've been for the last
week but you need your bill is [__]
growing and I'm charging you interest on
my Liz she goes what's in the bag I'm
trying to solve this okay I'm really
working large because I found that you
owe somebody else you didn't know about
J Brand Jay was the guy of 40 to 50 yeah
so I go listen you see this weed here
it's came from or why this pound is like
1200 hours this is
talking yeah I could sell you either
your pants that right no Mike this long
I'm gonna do give me two months ago I
ain't giving you [__] but listen to me
I'm gonna give you two coke and the keys
to my house I will be back here and now
with your four thousand dollars yeah
she looked at me looked at me back and
forth uh-huh like why would I lie to you
I'm trying to make money plus I'm not a
thousand off our tab ah this is how good
of a deal I've got mm-hmm as she's
looking she's like if you're not back in
an hour with my money I swear to god
they gotta shoot you in the [__]
ahead I'm like fine give me the ounces
and give me the glass don't want me the
[__] you give the Russians all right
give me the glass so she's like yeah I
mean this coke was beautiful and she
goes when are you gonna be back yeah go
nine o'clock [__] you I got my car and
headed south holy [__] [__] is still
waiting the week so now this is 86
uh-huh I go to Aspen I go to Boulder did
you drive there drop the boulder from
Ashland okay gotcha we stopped at four
different hotels checked in and checked
out uh-huh we were going to a hotel
anything our stuff do two lines of coke
get paranoid and go really it was
horrible horrible Wow girl yeah well I
put this poor girl for no one that you
don't let me talk that's a lot do a line
of coke [__] look at each other for a
minute and go we gotta go would you get
your money back every time or you just
lost that money you would just leave Wow
do nothing
Wow so we did that we got back to
Boulder we finished a coke for two days
we [__] myself uh-huh and we had like
you know $60 mm-hmm I mean knowing this
is how much addict that we could have
sold an ounce to start a new wife right
I've made $2,000 we just did it yeah you
know that's the mind of an addict
sheriff [__] so I lived in Boulder I
got a rest of 88 yeah got married in 89
got separated 9191 I'm already doing
comedy
maybe that November I'm feeling bad
about myself
uh-huh I go let me go up to ask so four
years later I'm gonna go to a place
where I owe a hundred grand there's 50
people pissed off at haha you know they
back traced and realized what I had the
damage I had done yeah III yes
shoplifting and doing all this damage
mm-hmm and I rent the car and I go to
Aston and I go let me go to Snowmass
first the place where I actually owed
the [__] money right and I go to
Snowmass more whatever the mall is
calling up in the top yeah and there's a
parking right there what a surprise
and I get out of the car and I'm not in
the mall I walk it's an outdoor mall I'm
gonna go to get at ball with Stuart the
stewpot yeah Jesus Christ
Oh walks up the name of this new girl
he's like man I hate doing great to see
I gave him a hug like nothing happened
not my heart would beat a little bit I
didn't have a weapon on me I didn't know
what was going on
yeah we hugged he asked me what was
going on I said I lived in [__] alder
down I'm doing stand-up comedy uh-huh
and he goes that's great you're just
gonna ask you something what about him -
that money you owed me I know brother it
was truck money it was water under the
bridge
uh-huh you should tell him he walked
away Wow
he just let you out dude what do you do
what can he do what can you do as a
human being like what can you do like
there was a one guy owed money to him
bold I know exactly how much I'm sixteen
hundred yeah he was a sweetheart of a
guy I called him back on not three years
if I send in the money oh cool yeah
nice number sixteen fifty and I'm
electron you're on top nice he was so
happy
yeah that's girl there was some people
who I beat that I feel bad about there's
other people who played the game and
weren't prepared for it right
you know when my world you after the
first 10,000 I got to put a bullet in
you like you're right because if not the
war
gonna get out there you could beat me
yeah and that can't get out cuz there's
my business yeah since he didn't shoot
me other than smack they didn't do
nothing so what are you gonna do what's
the chick gonna do right what is she
gonna do no she's not willing what's the
other one yeah the last one the one I
told you I get the wheat that she was he
in there oh yeah she's somebody's
personal manager never system associate
if you run into her what do I give a
[__] I thought the sex book was 30 years
ago
suck my dick and call me shorty I was
born in 1940 gonna come hit me up you
tell them it's water under the bridge
[Laughter]
you got into the drug business you
weren't prepared to cover the spread
right and somebody beat you you got
[__] and you got fun and that's what
you were wide open
oh yeah it's gonna be fine nothing you
did none of this I used to have fun
that's all gentlemen fun of me and uncle
knocking on your door if you're in there
I'm gonna kill you now giggle in the
back ride with a gun you're gonna do
nothing because that door I'm wish you
to ride the [__] egg you really like
Scarface doing lines and holding a gun
and watching your door that's so funny
that's sick
that's so funny and you but you didn't
go to a or anything did you you just
figured it out I just figured yeah I
tried going a couple nah it wasn't for
me gotcha
I just but you get to a point where
you're crawling on the floor
I still remember dumping an ounce in the
toilet flushing it and then the coke
stuck to the side of the toilet hotel
and me taking my friend yeah licking it
all right right I mean who would and
stick it in my nose yeah okay juice yeah
I was sticking in my nose I mean this is
the sickness
yes the mind of an addict right I'm
happy you won't be gone to that [__]
down nah yeah
reefer is the only way reefers the
shitty for never made nobody well you
couldn't Oh somebody 40,000 if you want
it no way unless you bought the farm
come up being a week now have you cash
okay for the farm for the crops what
yeah don't do that last night it's just
it's just a sick life yeah it seems like
so long ago oh it's gonna be fine Lee
nah [__] it
and now Joey died for your sins now
you're on way too high and and drinking
smoothies what's I got vanilla that's
just crazy up here things can change
things have to change
I guess so you can't yeah listen I
didn't I did some you're like girl well
when I talk about it here and how she
took my daughter and all that [__] I
don't even want people to think I was an
innocent I'm saying that girl smarten up
one day and said what the [__] was I
gone uh-huh I put that poor girl through
six years ago right being in her
brother's wedding party mm-hmm and ugh
leaving on Wednesday go and see you're
flying in a Saturday morning me like
yeah we're gonna and she said bring the
coke I had this pink coat uh-huh it was
so glad to once again she flew with it
don't we say okay over this safe gotcha
it was so good that I gave it to you and
said hold it in your safe gotcha and I
was no attrition friend of mine right I
go hold it to your safe till this date I
don't want that coconut cold pick it up
on this thing yeah and I went up to that
house and one o'clock on a Friday I was
supposed to be on a plane on Saturday
morning at 8:00 to get the boulder it
late and AH and the wedding was that one
uh-huh when I got to my buddy's I went
home at 3 o'clock I so let me just do a
blast and the blast do you know she came
back on Wednesday uh and I had not I was
still snoring Tuesday she walked in and
I was doing the talent ed of the last
half-hour right never made it to the
wedding
dead the [__] dog didn't pee oh I
didn't let the dog out for the first 25
he was by the door just look
that me yeah repeat I'm a lot of his
[__] to you yeah I mean it was a
different [__] world yeah you know
it's gonna be November 8th that's gonna
be 12 years oh my good
yeah man yeah that's it becomes a job
you never got hooked on metal no I mean
I used to be way more into booze uh than
I am now I used to drink a lot but I
don't know it didn't it didn't really
disrupt my life as far as I know but you
know they put me in a lot of bad moods
that's for [__] sure
real quick before I go any further I
gotta read a quick ad before I forget
because I always [__] forget listen
the church will tapping now is sponsored
by upstart most of us find out the hard
way but getting into debt is easy like
what just discuss now can getting out is
hard especially if your credit score
isn't that great they offer you smaller
interest rates to help you pay off
credit card debt
that's what upstart does okay listen up
start could help me it could help to any
of us with debt
imma start goes beyond the traditional
credit score your upstart interest rate
is based on your education job history
not your credit score they actually
reward you for going to school so
upstart doesn't care about the bills you
didn't pay five years ago they care
about the person you are now today and
they give you a rate based on that plus
they make it fast simple and easy to
check your rate in just a few minutes
without affecting your credit score the
best part once the loan is approved and
most people get their funds the very
next day the next day over three hundred
thousand people have used I've start to
pay off credit cards free yourself from
the burden the high interest credit card
debt by consolidating everything into
one monthly payment will up start see
why upstart is ranked number one in that
category with over three hundred
businesses on Trustpilot
hurry up to hub start da upstart com
slash Church to find out how low your up
start rate
is listen all days are coming you need
cash you're running out of cash
things are go to abstract calm right now
/ Church checking your rate only takes a
few minutes and it won't affect your
credit that's upstart calm / Church
holidays are coming you want to clear up
some credit cards this is the way they
go up start Matt what's on tap for you
uh the podcast just came out today Road
heads on iTunes another podcast well the
full charge Power Hour that's a lot of
fun if you want to listen to that say
that with I do that with a guy a friend
of mine named Craig Coleman okay um and
I got a movie reviewer it's a little out
of his mind
he's the star of the show he says the
craziest [__] things check that out
the full charge calm and [__] am i I'm
doing I'm doing a show with you coming
up aren't I
maybe I think you told me in New York
and Massachusetts but if I'm wrong I
don't know yeah okay okay okay I thought
you mentioned that okay well I'm doing
that I'm in Atlantic City if you don't
want to do that it's fine I did okay
Atlantic City first week in November I'm
doing the Borgata and I'm going to
Australia with Tom Segura in January the
world yeah man it's exciting and you're
right there in the middle and you're
still coming up with new merch and
always killing from hey thanks man
that's why usually thank you [__]
Savage Thank You Man I appreciate that a
long time ago absolutely [__] comedy
comedy still a baby
potluck potluck is when we met yeah yeah
I [__] love that full truck
the years are going buddy but we're
still I know I can game just keep going
and that's all that [__] man what
else is there to do what do you got
scheduled for this week this week coming
yeah I'm doing the Ice House on Tuesday
I'm doing the Laugh Factory tonight I'm
doing the Long Beach Laugh Factory on
Wednesday and I'm doing the Ontario
improv all weekend what Chris Porter
opener for Christmas yeah okay good
Fianna so check me out if you're gonna
[__] roll oh dude
I do the stand-up comedy I can't stop
this is why you know anyway yeah I'm
happy you came on yeah
is the best I love hanging with you
[__] yes listen don't go nowhere
do not forget 11 [__] 8 and 11 9
November 8th and 9th I'm at the funny
bone in Omaha Nebraska and then November
29th and 30th I'm at the [__]
Miami improv and do not forget we just
added a second show in New York City at
town hall on the 6th that's it and
that's death real quick before you get
the [__] out of here let me talk to you
about a few [__] things comes like
this area number one like I told you in
the beginning listen with six seven
weeks into football and you're still
[__] around
all right why you keep picking winners
and not betting them is beyond me that's
why I go to my book it's fast it's easy
and they pay when you went let's face it
where you're betting is just as
important as where you're betting on so
stop [__] around if you're trying to
blame the NFL the World Series you and
see whatever my bookies got it I
wouldn't be telling you guys to bet with
them if they're not the [__] best out
there so do the smart thing if you got a
bet this football season back with my
bookie did you know you can bet on games
have to kickoff you got options with my
bookie if by the second half it looks
like your bets gonna lose who gives a
[__] you can always take the other side
that's the kind of [__] my bookie does
if you're the kind of guy who likes to
bet a little and win a lot
you better [__] parlay if the big
scum crew you multiply your [__]
winnings and no matter how your bet the
NFL season is the best time of year cuz
right now you got to [__] listen
starting next week it's just basketball
the lines are soft if you're not back
then be a next week go [__] yourself I'm
telling you to make money
everybody knows about the NFL line
you're [__] dead but with basketball
you can make money so double your
deposit today use promo code Church to
get a hundred percent bonus on your
initial deposit I join what the [__] are
you talking about what I'm telling you
is if you give me a nickel I'll match a
nickel that's what my bookie done for
you who else does that for you nobody
go to my bookie that AG that's my bookie
grab that [__] pen again you dumb
[__] my bo o ki e dot AG and don't
forget to use promo code Church when
creating your account to claim the bonus
and don't forget with my bookie
you play you win you get paid don't
forget to check my Instagram Thursday
I'm dropping a video from my bookie on
their how to make bets and whatnot all
right you'll be saying uncle Joey is my
[__] bookie go to mad flavours world
right now go to my bookie da AG antic
old Church and W deposit it's that easy
the church would also love to thank the
zip recruit let me tell you a little
story about you know Dylan Alaska which
is Dylan mature which is a zip recruit a
customer you zip recruited the higher
for his company Cafe el Toro they got a
standard testimonial from this guy
alright hiring can be a slow process but
I felt or was CEO Dylan Moskowitz needed
to hire a director of coffee for his
organic coffee company but he was having
a little trouble finding a qualified
candidate what did he do he went to zip
recruiter zip recruiter doesn't depend
on candidates finding you that's never
gonna happen it finds the best quality
candidates for you if technology
identifies people with the right
experience and invites them to apply to
your job alright so you get qualified
candidates quick
Dylan posted his job on zip recruiter
and said he was impressed on how quickly
he had a great candidate supply he also
used rip recruiting the candidates
rating feature to filter his applicants
so he could focus on the most relevant
ones and guess what
Dylan found the director of quality in
just a few days with results like that
it's no wonder four out of five
employees who post on zip recruited get
quality candidates within the first day
what did I just say the first day the
first day okay listen you're a
businessman you own a business with a
small or large you don't have time to
play fun and games you want to get the
qualified people nice and quick that CY
zipper cool is effective
for all businesses of all sizes whether
you're all a bakery or you have a sweat
shop zip recruiter get out dot-com slash
church again that's zipper cool calm
slash Church
si-hu rch zip recruited calm slash
Church zipper cool the smartest way to
hide listen do you having a hard time
your credit cards
Johnny boombots this that's Hollywood is
coming the church is sponsored by up
star you like Joey what's up start I'm
starting off with use smaller interest
rates to help you pay off your credit
card debt I told you during the middle
of a podcast obstruct goes beyond the
traditional credit score that's why I
love upstart so do me a favor see why
I'm starting is ranked number one in
that category with over three hundred
businesses on Trustpilot hurry up start
calm slash Church to find out how low
your upstate upstart rate is checking
your rain only takes a few minutes and
it won't affect your credit score
alright so do me a favor go to upstart
calm slash Church I want to thank i'ma
start I want to thank super cruder and I
want to thank my bookie but most
importantly I want to thank you
[__] for always having my back
do not forget about my man Matt bull
Tron this week if you're in the LA area
come by this guy's my main man we go on
the road together he's my brother
and he's funny is [__] and don't forget
two weeks the funny bone Omaha Nebraska
get those [__] steaks ready time
something get those states ready and
Thanksgiving weekend I'll be at the
[__] Miami and probably Friday and
Saturday December 6 with Matt boltron in
Manhattan rocking you [__]
second shows banana cut this [__] go the
Joey Diaz dotnet for all the details
and everything you got going on and
that's it and that's that it's [__]
Tuesday go out there and knock him out
of a park look somebody and tell them
suck your dick it's that type of day
alright I want to thank Matt full try
Thank You Jay I want to thank you guys I
want to thank the [__] crazy
[__]
I want to thank you guys have been loyal
if always being family from
he's spooky too my man in Chicago the
[__] all you [__] out there
and those watching to turn Michael all
you [__] stay black have a
great day
kick this [__] me only a little Tony
Bennett these [__]